[Music]
philosophy has often been seen as a hunt
for a theory of everything a single
grand narrative that explains it all
in recent times science has had its own
supporters for a theory of everything
yet no theory of everything in
philosophy or science is forthcoming and
is it even possible
it would have to after all include
itself
can we conceive of a universe that also
includes its causes and its laws
can a universe have no before or after
no outside
and isn't a theory of everything itself
bounded by its particular culture its
language and its mode of thinking
so
should we abandon the dream of the
theory of everything simply see it as an
illusion born of a hubris
is the mistake not with the idea of a
full explanation but with the idea of
everything or as the greeks would have
said the one
[Music]
or is it just possible that as stephen
hawkins once believed a theory of
everything is just around the corner
ladies and gentlemen my name is
professor catherine heymans i am the
astronomer roar for scotland and it is
my great pleasure tonight to host the
end of everything and we will be
answering the question should we abandon
the dream of the theory of everything i
have four amazing speakers uh with me
this evening um we have eric weinstein
he is an american podcast host he is the
managing director of teal capital uh one
of the founding members of the
intellectual dark web and a doctor of
mathematical physics his geometric unity
theory of everything has been both
praised and criticized by the academic
community
savina hosenfelder is a theoretical
physicist at frankfurt institute of
advanced studies she specializes in
quantum gravity she's also a
best-selling author and look out for her
new book this summer existential physics
a scientist's guide to life's biggest
questions sabine also has a very popular
youtube channel check it out science
without the gobbledygook we're brian
green a professor of mathematics and
physics at the university of columbia he
is both famous for his groundbreaking
discoveries in string theory and his
best-selling books the most recent which
is entitled until the end of time mind
matter and our search or meaning in an
evolving universe and finally last but
by no means least michael sharma science
writer historian founder of the skeptic
society and editor-in-chief of its
magazine skeptic he is also a
best-selling author uh his recent book
giving the devil his due explores uh the
concepts of free speech and
interestingly ideas of controversial
intellectuals i wonder if we will be
controversial enough for you this
evening michael um i am going to invite
all of my speakers to answer a question
for me the question is is it possible to
find a theory of everything they have
two minutes each and we're going to
start off with brian green brian is it
possible
to find a theory of everything well i
should say at the outset that i am not a
fan of the phrase theory of everything
because
the number of issues that it raises some
of which you summarize in your opening
remarks quite well
are enormous
and it also from a sociological
standpoint
makes an odd statement within the
community if you say that you're working
on the theory of everything and
someone's not working on it or something
like it then what are they working on
nothing
and so it's it's it's not a it's not a
good phrasing to use even though it is
quite commonplace instead
i think a better phrasing is the search
for
ever deeper principles that unify our
understanding of the world and by that i
simply mean
you could explain the world by simply
giving a list of all of the physical
facts about the world it would be a very
unwieldy explanation the world wouldn't
give you much insight at all so that's
why that's typically not the approach we
take and say we try to find patterns in
the world encapsulate those patterns in
physical law
and then be able to describe a wealth of
phenomenon from a few principles
and the smaller the number of principles
and the greater the range of phenomena
we can describe the better and more
potent we consider our explanations and
historically that's exactly
what has happened even if that wasn't
initially the motivation right i mean
isaac newton
showed that physics here on earth and
physics up there in the sky all governed
by the same basic law of gravity and
then you've got
maxwell and and others in the 1800s
showing that electricity and magnesium
faraday come together
into a unified theory of electricity and
magnetism they're deeply related
patterns that put things together
einstein comes along and shows us that
space and time that we thought were
distinct they're actually unified in the
special theory of relativity and then he
puts gravity into that mix with the
general theory of relativity and you
fast forward into the
60s and 70s and scientists abdus salaam
and glashow and weinberg put together
one of the nuclear forces the weak
nuclear force with electricity and
magnetism unifying them into one
theoretical structure called the electro
weak theory and so this pattern of
unification smaller number of principles
greater explanatory reach has been what
we've seen played out the big question
is
will this continue
right i mean in america when you
invest in some kind of fund they always
say you know past results are not
indicative of future success the same
may be true here right
but certainly we're going to have to put
gravity and quantum mechanics together
that next stage of unity i think is
pretty uncontroversial that it needs to
happen whether we have it now or not is
debatable and worth discussing but
whether this then categorizes or should
be described as a theory of everything
no it's not a theory of everything
it would be a theory of the fundamental
ingredients the fundamental laws that
describe them it's a much less ambitious
approach to understanding the world
uh sabina is it possible to find a
theory of everything
well i i wouldn't say it's impossible
but i think it's not something i'm going
to see in my lifetime uh though i should
put ahead that like brian i'm not a fan
of the phrase theory of everything
because it raises a lot of
thorny issues and people tend to
misunderstand it
physicists who work in the foundations
of physics mean something very specific
by a theory of everything
which is a
unified description of all the
fundamental forces of nature that we
currently know of which besides gravity
are the three forces in the standard
model and so we have those four forces
they kind of sit a little bit awkward
next to each other and one of the big
thorny questions is um
why is gravity not a quantum
force
and that discrepancy has to be resolved
somehow so so the quantization of
gravity is part of this theory of
everything uh but also physicists would
like all these forces to come out of one
simple uh prescription
now um the question whether such a
theory theory would actually explain
everything um
i think no one really knows it's
generally assumed that if we had
succeeded in uh unifying those forces
that would also explain some of the
puzzles that we have like for example
what stuck matter what what is dark
energy uh it would resolve singularities
it would explain what happens inside of
black holes whether such a theory
actually would do this
we don't know
and i'm i'm very skeptical that any of
the current approaches to such a theory
of everything um will actually work
the the reason is
quite simply that none of those theories
ever address what in my mind is the
biggest problem that's the measurement
problem in quantum mechanics so none of
those theories would actually explain
what a detector is and and i would say
well if you have a theory of everything
that doesn't tell me what a detector is
that's a poor theory of everything
because the detector is clearly
something
now when it comes to those more
philosophical questions like can a
theory actually explain itself
i think i'm not the right person to ask
well we will come on to that sabina
thank you very much um eric please do
unmute yourself and tell us is it
possible to find a theory of everything
since i've addressed this elsewhere let
me just say yes so that we can have more
time for the debate and that's of course
up to the caveats about
uh not being able to compute everything
from it so thanks for him brilliant
thank you eric and finally uh michael
sherman is it possible to find a theory
of everything
well i'll take eric's one and a half
minutes left
i think so in the physical sciences from
a history of science perspective it
seems that the direction
uh that physicists are moving
given brian's caveats
uh from there probably not uh because so
much of the biological and social
sciences deal with emergent properties
that are not predictable and cannot be
derived out of
uh sort of reductionistic uh more
fundamental principles so say take
darwin's
theory of evolution which is the closest
we have in the biological sciences to a
theory of everything but even there
there's so many wrinkles on it and
applying it to say darwinian medicine or
evolutionary psychology it's still much
of human behavior is quite unpredictable
because it it's emergent from other
phenomena that are not directly derived
from these more fundamental principles
and if you move to the social sciences
and you say well where is
where can we how do we explain
unemployment so the economist studies
unemployment where is unemployment in in
any kind of physics or biological
theories it's not
uh or the study of human conflict or
violence or deaths of despair opioid
crisis uh
you you know you name it all of these
things uh have to be studied as emergent
properties of their own there's not
going to be any theory of everything
because in most cases you're lucky if
you can reduce it to half a dozen
variables controlling for all these
others and even their prediction is
extremely difficult so that said i think
there is an appeal to it because it
feels like you're moving into
almost a theological realm of you know
we'll know the mind of god you know and
when stephen hawking wrote that you know
of course theologians went crazy like ah
the great stephen hawking supports us so
i have a whole book on this subject
called the borderlands of science in
which i talk about theories of
everything including a fellow so these
people send me these theories pretty
much every month i get them i have filed
cabinets full of theories of everything
these are not the kind of stuff that
eric
and brian and sabine are working on the
this guy writes by the way he has the
url
www.theory of everything.com so sorry
it's been taken
and so i always write these people back
and say well why don't you try uh
talking to a physicist about this and
like this guy then responded i sent it
to many scientists but nobody interested
so far and many of them said boy don't
be stupid nobody can discover such a
theory a theory of everything it's too
crazy it's impossible it'd be like
knowing the mind of god
if you're not interested please don't
write me anymore spare me your critical
view so god to me is logic therefore god
to me is the law of logic
so i have hundreds of these kinds of
things there's an appeal to it like if i
can get this then i i'm going to be the
next einstein or fimen or newton or
whatever
and and so it most likely of course none
of these are true but i i think beyond
the physical sciences it's probably a
fruitless
endeavor thank you very much michael so
you can see uh ladies and gentlemen we
have a kind of a range of opinions there
on what a theory of everything is
whether it's possible whether it's not
and our first theme for our debate this
evening is
would a theory of everything answer all
our fundamental questions about the
universe including the existence of the
theory itself
and uh we're going to start off with
brian uh to answer this question
well again i've already given my
misgivings about thinking in terms of
the theory of everything at all so i
won't retread that
particular answer but i think
michael's comment
is a fertile place to begin an answer to
that question because in many ways i
agree with what michael just mentioned
there are all sorts of phenomenon that
happen at a variety of scales in the
world right we physicists or at least be
particle physicists tend to focus upon
the electrons the quarks the fundamental
constituents and the fundamental laws
that govern their behaviors but when you
have a lot of particles come together
into a macroscopic system there are
behaviors that emerge in that system
that would be very hard to explain at
the level of the fundamental particles i
mean even a simple thing as a baseball
flying
in a baseball game if you were to
describe it in terms of the motion of
the individual constituents
it'd be this mountain of data describing
each and every particle
and it would give no insight much more
useful is describe it as a baseball
flying through the air in the way that
say isaac newton would have described
that kind of an object
so it's important to recognize that the
world is striated into a variety of
scales there's phenomena that happens at
different scales and what we found is
it's best to use the variables and the
ideas that are most relevant to the
scale of the question being asked
baseball or human beings you don't want
to answer in terms of particles but you
talk about the spectrum of hydrogen when
it's excited then yeah you do want to be
right down there at the quantum
mechanical level and describing during
their particles now the one thing i
would add to that though and i don't
know if this is controversial or if
michael or others would find this
controversial i would take exceptions
one thing that michael said i would say
that emergent phenomena in principle
are determined by the fundamental laws
that govern the basic ingredients i
don't think there's anything else beyond
the fundamental ingredients ingredients
and the fundamental laws it's
extraordinarily difficult and largely a
fool's errand to try to describe
unemployment
using the standard model of particle
physics of course but is there something
else beyond the particles and the laws
no so in principle if you follow the
particles and you follow the laws
and you could do an unimaginable
calculation that we can't possibly do
but in principle would you know that a
certain collection of particles at some
particular point in time exhibit the
behavior that we would call being
unemployed
yeah
yeah in principle yes
in principle needs to be underscored for
a variety of different reasons
but i don't think there's anything else
that intervenes beyond the ingredients
and the laws
okay so you just need to define those
ingredients and then everything else
follows
in principle yes
what else would there be
yeah
what else would there be not not any
ghost in the machine no external uh
extra sensory or supernatural powers
intervening no
but um
if the universe is not predetermined we
live in a determined universe with cause
and effect but not predetermined
then the outcome is not predictable in
not even in principle
not even laplace's demon that knows
every particle and every motion and so
forth can predict what is that what does
that mean
can you just clarify what you mean again
in principle there's a quantum
mechanical calculation that won't
predict what will happen but we'll
predict the probability of what will
happen and then as sabina mentioned
there is this issue of the quantum
measurement problem that is unresolved i
agree with what spina said completely
that's the missing piece but if we put
that to the side just for having this
conversation i would say that the
probabilities are in principle
determined
by
the collection of particles that are
engaged in whatever macroscopic system
you're talking about
interesting yeah so this kind of touches
on almost the free will determinism
problem oh see here again
from free will yeah doesn't exist
so if you just take like opioid
addiction you could drill down to the
molecular level of synaptic
transmissions of
you know neural chemical transmitter
substances and how they're affected by
uh
cocaine or whatever
and and then from there scale up but at
some point it seems to me that the
system is so complex and the person
himself or herself is an active agent
within the causal net of the universe
and at some point just decides i'm gonna
do i'm gonna go left instead of right
i'm gonna i'm gonna you know control my
addiction or i'm not and we know some
people can do this and some can't so
it's not that it's determined
in the future that we already know
exactly if we knew every particle which
which every every person that would be
an addict and which or not
that in fact there's an element of
volition in there of knowing what the
causal vectors are and what you could do
to control the forthcoming your future
self and and kind of predetermining your
own future self by taking some control
over those variables here it's a kind of
a semantic game maybe but like that's
what you mean by bullets
i just wouldn't confuse
predictability in the sense of being
able to do the calculation
with
some kind of volition which to me is a
ghost in the machine
if it's not the particles and laws of
physics if you're saying there's
something else you got to tell me what
that something else is and i know you
well enough to know that you don't think
there's anything else no no no of course
not no
but self-awareness awareness of the
factors sorry yeah go ahead so i'm going
to bring in eric here so eric uh lisa
mullen he's described where we're at in
physics at the moment with the the
principles that that brian's talking
about here that
that infers everything he's described
physicists like biologists before darwin
that we're we're missing a really big
picture so so what's what's your
thoughts on this you know we
we're in danger of spending the hour on
the issue of computability and effective
theories and and i think everybody's
probably agreed there is no way in
theory even brian will not say
that the computation is possible you can
show that the system can't compute
itself so let's agree that um the first
issue is
that we have to understand that the
theory of everything if it is to be
given meaning and to evade brian's
criticism has to be narrowed it's not
the colloquial sense it has to do with
finding the rules of chess if the
universe was chess by observing chess
games it doesn't tell you how to play
chess and it doesn't necessarily tell
you who created chess right
so what i've tried to say concretely is
is that i believe
that
our particular universe and just to give
you grist for actual debate where we
where we will disagree um i am betting
that the universe uh
is determined by a four four-dimensional
orientable manifold with a unique spin
structure that that would be sufficient
to generate three families of
fermions with the observed quantum
numbers
as well as geometric laws for the metric
and also just to
possibly give some region for debate
i would also say that quantum gravity is
not the only way of harmonizing
the standard model with einstein's
theory of general relativity necessarily
and that there was a little bit of a
three-card monty um played in the late
70s early 80s where we went from unified
field theory towards quantum gravity
which very much favored quantum field
theorists in the what used to be high
energy physics which has now become no
energy physics because most of it isn't
really about physics at all i mean were
we to read through the archive today uh
none of us could contain our sense of
embarrassment of doing this in front of
a thousand people so i think that that's
our paper repository i think that the
important thing to say is that a theory
of everything as a physical theory is
one which demotivates physicists to keep
working on the problem of the rules of
chess if the universe was chess and
hands it over to philosophers we don't
know where the number seven comes from
but i know very few mathematicians who
spend their time worrying about the
origin of that numeral so i think that
it's very important to actually
understand that the most audacious thing
that we can say
is that we are extremely close
uh in some of our estimations to a
theory of everything
properly scoped so as not to include the
issue of effective theories computation
or the origins of an initial set i don't
think that you and catherine you
actually entered the debate when you
said that in your initial statement so i
think you're now a participant
um and i i heartily disagree with your
opening statement that it should contain
itself in fact um it should that it
should go over to the philosophers and
theologians to ask
what the initial conditions are all
about and
by the way by initial i don't mean in
time because time itself is part of the
story i think what i what i'm really
trying to say is you have to postulate
that there is something rather than
nothing and then the idea is is that no
physicist should be motivated to
continue that search
been i'm going to bring you in here
because i've been you've been
uncharacteristically quiet until this
point so
i think you'll agree with some of the
things that eric just said but but not
all
yeah so but i think i i'm going to do
the boring thing and we'll try to
actually answer the question which you
ask whether theory can explain itself my
answer would be
not within the confines of science to
begin with because the purpose of
science is to explain observations the
purpose of science is not to
explain the theories that are supposed
to explain uh the observations unless i
mean you you you mean this in the
colloquial sense like that i'm trying to
explain to you how quantum mechanics
works that kind of thing
uh but there's also another way to see
what the problem is um so
one of the requirements we have of a
theory of everything a fundamental
theory of nature is that it's internally
consistent which is exactly what we
currently don't have like if we just
take all those four interactions uh
standard model and and gravity and we
throw them together that's not
internally consistent which is why we
think there has to be a theory of
quantum gravity
um
but um if you only have this requirement
of consistency there are lots of
theories out there you know there are
lots of sets of axioms that are um
axiomatically consistent and their only
shortcoming is that they don't describe
what we see you know you can make up a
theory about an empty universe that
doesn't contain any matter and there
wouldn't be anything wrong with it other
than that it's not the universe we
inhabit
uh which means that whatever this theory
is this theory of everything
some of the answers it will give is just
it's because
that's what we observe
because we need this to pick one
specific theory the universe is one way
and not another um basically so this is
why i think um
a theory that describes everything we
observe would still have some unanswered
questions
um just because it will have certain
ingredients that we have to pick to
describe uh what we observe
one of the things that i think might be
interesting uh for sabine and i to chew
over is i actually think that it's not
just uh to explain experiment a really
good theory
should actually challenge things that we
think we know to be true that turn out
are not true
and one of the things that i find very
interesting is the number of theories
that are as timid as possible like you
know a sterile neutrino theory
which attempts to say as little beyond
the standard model in gravity uh as we
can so i think that a really good theory
should actually point and say you are
how sure are you about all these things
you think you've observed
furthermore
i think that it's also possible you know
i heard sabine say
quantum gravity
if you think about going the opposite
direction einstein's theory was
initially geometric uh whereas the the
quantum dependent on calculus and linear
algebra
and what really happened is we went in
exactly the opposite direction we didn't
quantize gravity we geometrized the
quantum from the period of the early to
mid 70s
through this explosion
largely due to the string theorists not
doing string theory but instead
geometrizing quantum field theory in the
80s and 90s
and so really
things have been going in the other
direction where the children of einstein
have been
more effective at transforming the uh
thinking process of the children of bohr
and so i think instead of thinking about
quantum gravity we should
uh pull back and say we we need to
harmonize the two theories rather than
force gravity to submit to the quantum
thank you eric well if i if i can
briefly um if i can briefly respond
i actually agree i think this is this is
an issue of terminology so when i say
quantum gravity i don't necessarily mean
you have to quantize gravity but there's
any kind of theory that resolves the
inconsistency between the quantized
quantum theories and gravity
thanks sabina so
we have uh uh the highlight talk after
our debate this evening by michio kaku
and he's very focused on the history of
physics the fact that it can be
characterized by unification so of
course we have um newton with the theory
of the heavens uh fantastic maxwell uh
unifying um electromagnetism and brian i
know you know you've spent your life
working on string theory which is
looking at unifying electromagnetism the
strong and the weak theory you know why
do you think
historically we have been so fixated on
on trying to get this theory of
everything um you know you've been
working on this for 30 years brian so
you must be
slightly fixated on it
well first off i wouldn't say that the
goal of string theory is to unify all
the forces of nature i would say that's
an interesting byproduct of the theory
the real motivation for string theory is
what we just heard from eric and sabine
is a particular approach to trying to
resolve this incompatibility between the
traditional formulation of quantum
mechanics and the traditional
formulation of the general theory of
relativity einstein's theory of gravity
and strength theory is simply one
approach which
at least on paper
shows great promise to blend these two
theories into a mathematically
consistent framework now when you study
that theory in detail
you can extract a very satisfying
unification that does continue the work
of of newton and the work of faraday and
maxwell and the work of salaam and and
weinberg and glashow because it does
naturally put together the fundamental
forces gravity electromagnetism the weak
and strong nuclear forces and gravity
they're all put together into one
unified rubric they're all the result of
certain kinds of vibrations of this
hypothetical ingredient called a strain
so it's not the motivation it's really
the the outcome but i will say that i
certainly agree with you that
historically even beyond physics
we do see a kind of human drive toward
unity and maybe maybe michael can give
us the philosophical or evolutionary
psychological reason for that i mean you
can see that
in the world's religions right there's a
time when
many of the world's religions had many
different deities and then at some point
some religions tend to consolidate and
come to a monotheistic unification if
you will of those kinds of
forces and you know i i even had a i did
a program just the other day on
something non-physics at all it's about
psychedelics okay and the people that i
was talking to who are deeply involved
in psychedelics they see psychedelics as
a unified theory of everything of human
consciousness it's as if you know any
area that you're within you talk to a
priest religion's the unified theory of
everything so i think there's a human
tendency
for
a desire for our ideas of the moment to
have incredibly large explanatory reach
so maybe that's part of the drive but
for string theory and for physics more
generally it's more what sabine was
saying we have certain data
about the world we're trying to explain
that data in the most straightforward
and predictive means possible we come up
with certain mathematical theories
quantum mechanics and general relativity
the standard model be among those and we
want those theories to talk to each
other in a mathematically consistent way
and at the moment they don't
now the world's a consistent place so
our description needs to be consistent
and that is really what motivates us to
try to go the next step and again string
theory is just one possible way that may
or may not
be the way to do that
thanks brian eric do you feel fixated in
the search the theory of everything you
know you said quite confidently at the
start that you believed that it was
possible to find one and you have your
your own theory
look the answer to this question changed
in 1952.
uh in less than six months between 1952
and 1953
um we successfully fused nuclei and
caused an island in the pacific to
disappear as well as we entered the
cell and found the three-dimensional
structure of dna and the genetic code 10
years after
we're going to die here very soon and by
soon i mean
a few hundred years at most almost
certainly we're having a cigar party and
a fireworks display while perched on a
propane tank
you can see from for example the fact
that we're all wearing these masks
people haven't even figured out that
they're going to have to buy hazmat
suits if we start having thermonuclear
exchanges i'm not kidding at all about
this
um so the new reason to do this isn't
the beauty of gazing into the night sky
or man's quest to know
his place in the universe if we don't
figure out how to spread out we are
running one single experiment with
god-like powers in the wisdom of morons
based on our current political
leadership there is no way that this
terminates well
furthermore there is no faster than
light travel inside of general
relativity so you can look up at the
night sky and you can know more or less
than unless you're betting on time
dilation and other exotic effects and
wormholes
we aren't going any place there are only
three habitable spheres
now the world's richest people two of
them bezos and musk are focused on
rockets to get us into space one of us
thinks that we can diversify with three
spheres the other seems to think the
gerald k o'neill's circular space
stations with artificial gravity are the
way to go bezos actually makes more
sense neither of these make much sense
at all
and the odd thing to say and again that
you know i don't want to go too much
into social commentary is is that um if
we could only get physics to be vaguely
phallic
in shape load it with high explosives
and oxidizers we could get fully funded
and i think we'd probably have a theory
within 20 years at the moment
nobody seems to be motivated on the idea
that you break it you bought it physics
has a ton of social responsibility
we unleashed this power i encourage
everyone to read edward teller's letter
to leo zillard at the end of the
manhattan project and to reevaluate
their theories of edward teller his idea
was is that war had to become so
unthinkable that we could never have
another
and 75 years of this piece have dulled
our sensibilities forgetting that
nuclear weapons have not gone away and
we've added biologicals if we're not
very careful we are going to have to go
farther through the valley of death that
physics has led us into if we are ever
to escape diversify and have some hope
that some of us at least will make it in
the long term
oh eric i'm off on a tangent from the
theory of everything but i'm feeling a
bit depressed now um
you have a chance to survive catherine
you have an opportunity because you know
hamiltonian dynamics and lagrangians and
all that to work on an escape plan in
fact i would say we have an obligation
um to uh i think teller's comment was
to tie the toe of the genie from the
bottle we helped it to escape if the
theory of everything exists it renders
einstein and and
the standard model as effective theories
to be deduced from the underlying theory
we don't know
whether an analog
of the prohibition on faster than light
travel persists into a lower layer until
we have such a theory so it could be
that if you had the theory of everything
you could prove that you will never
meaningfully escape the solar system
eric is saying
we must pursue this theory of everything
because because
fundamentally humanity needs to escape
and go somewhere else diversify yeah
um so i'm i'm doing something very
shocking now i actually i'll actually
agree with eric uh which is that i i
think physicists totally underestimate
their responsibility uh and i think the
the relevance of the foundations of
physics at this point in the history of
time is totally underestimated you know
we need some new technologies we're kind
of running out of ideas here and i think
they have to come from the foundations
of physics now where we start to
disagree is uh is exactly where those
new ideas uh should be coming from and
um i don't really think that quantum
gravity is the right direction to look
i've i've worked for a long time in
quantum gravity
um i i don't think that looking for
mathematical consistency is the right
thing to do but we should be looking for
um experimental evidence and i i can
talk about this for some time but the
point is that all those effects of
quantum gravity they're like really
really small and even though i think
that they're super important to
understand the universe i can't really
see that they're going to be technology
technologically relevant in the near
future which is why as of recently i'm
more working in the direction of the
foundations of
quantum mechanics where we're talking
about the measurement problem because
quantum mechanics is
the theoretical framework that underlies
all our current technology and if we
understand this better if we figure out
that this is not fundamentally the right
thing to do that's going to impact all
our technologies and it's almost
certainly going uh to lead to
applications
thanks sabina now michael eric's just
upped the ante here saying we need a
theory of everything to to diversify and
save humanity so so where is that if if
if we really need to pursue that
where is that theory of everything going
to come from and you've wrote a really
interesting review of
margaret wertheim's book recently um
where you were saying that you were
becoming less dismissive of these
these theories of everything that you
were being sent that maybe mainstream
academic academic physics is is it's not
the place to look at these things i
wonder if you want to
expand on
yeah well first uh thanks for the cheery
uh monday morning eric we're all doomed
we only have a couple centuries to go we
got to go to mars and start a new human
colony i do support that idea just in
case but not not just in case we cause
our own extinction which is unlikely but
not impossible with nuclear weapons i
think you know it's just what we do as a
species we expand out and we explore new
uh
places and that's the next logical step
so let's do it okay good
um but if it was just for saving our our
species
uh we'd be far better putting the money
into research on game theory for example
and how
political leaders can solve conflicts or
how nations can solve conflicts and
what's the best structure for governance
of a collection of people to
reduce or attenuate the possibility of
of uh you know massive conflict that
could then escalate to using nuclear
weapons because we can't unlearn nuclear
physics and you know somebody on mars
5000 years from now could reinvent
nuclear weapons because the knowledge is
there
uh so it's better to i think to put it
in the human realm of how do we prevent
people from having those sorts of
conflicts that could ever escalate
uh to nuclear conflict and and and there
we've actually made a lot of progress we
we know we understand why
uh leaders do what they do and
uh but maybe there's a completely
different uh say i don't know if you
call it a theory of everything in
politics but let's say i wrote this
essay called governing mars all right
what kind of government governance
should we take with us well we've
learned a lot here on earth on the blue
planet so maybe we should take the best
of what we have to the red planet but
maybe
elon's engineers or his social
scientists or whoever
or the martians themselves centuries
from now will come up with some
completely different way of structuring
the economy and political systems that
we can't even think of that's way better
than democracy democracy is great you
know but it's you know it's not perfect
so maybe there's something that none of
us can think of and there i would like
to say we should have funding for that
you know just like okay you think of
something completely new that no one's
ever thought of okay second part to your
question i think is an epistemological
one how do you know
if somebody's theory of everything is
has any hope for succeeding here i have
a lot of experience in this because you
know most of these theories of
everything i get are in the physical
sciences and i always ask them why are
you asking me i'm i'm a social scientist
historian so i don't know anything about
physics you know go why don't you take
it to kip thorn at caltech and ask him
or michiokaku or brian or whatever
and they all they will never accept it
because you know they're they're
flatlanders and you know scientists are
dogmatic and close-minded and they can
never accept new ideas well if that was
true there'd be no progress in science
so obviously it's not true
so there's a reason for why scientists
tend to be skeptical of theories of
everything or any kind of
uh sort of fringe or or new idea that's
challenging the mainstream and that that
is because most new ideas are wrong
including those by a brilliant scientist
you know scientists are often just
spitballing ideas just trying to come up
with stuff that they can test and just
see how it floated out there to see how
it goes and most of the time it doesn't
go anywhere
i'll tell you a funny story stephen
wolfram who is the youngest phd ever at
caltech a super brilliant guy
mathematica and so on he wrote this book
called a new kind of science
and so
to my utter surprise he his office
called me and said well he'd like to
meet with you like me okay
so
and what do you want to know is as a
story of science how do scientific
revolutions come about because i kind of
like to bring out my own scientific
revolution with my new kind of science
it's like
it doesn't come from the top down you
can't just like orchestrate it you just
your ideas either lead to some new
fruitful research and other ideas by
graduate students and other professors
or it doesn't and usually it doesn't go
anywhere
and uh and he's like oh okay
and you know sort of following his work
again brilliant guy
wonderful ideas and so on i don't i
don't think it's changed the science
it either does or it doesn't so
there the best you could do is just kind
of put it out there to your colleagues
and and hope that it changes the way
they think and if it doesn't well that's
just the way it goes it probably is
probably not a fruitful idea
now now eric i'm going to bring you in
here because you you aren't coming from
mainstream academia you do of course
have a phd in mathematical physics but
your your theory of everything hasn't
gone through the peer review process
that the normal academic circle so
what's your your thought on this is
science being
um
slowed down by the academic pressures
that do we need to pay more attention to
um to non-mainstream ideas well most
non-mainstream ideas are lousy and um no
they are and
most mainstream i mean look the the
community that
um i've been most angry with the string
theory community
is not because string theory is a bad
idea there's nothing that the equations
aren't going to hurt you and the ideas
aren't going to hurt you it's just
the 80s version of string theory was
murderous the whole point was we've got
this there are only five theories we'll
go through them and then we'll tell you
the answer and everybody else is just a
poser
and they've not atoned for that sin and
it poisoned the entire culture now that
poisoning didn't happen
uniquely within physics unless you cross
fields and unless you've released the
theory of everything you have no idea of
the current state of academics i just
called for example peter white who runs
the blog not even wrong as a colleague
of brian's at columbia
and you know of course i read his new
foray into the world of theories of
everything
as i read stephen wolframs and garrett
lisi's and every one of these and in
general everyone who releases one has
the same reaction which is even if you
come from a position where you have a
phd and you come from the mainstream
the issue of reputational dynamics is
such that everyone is looking for a kill
shot how do i make peter white go away
so i never have to listen to him again
how do i protect my precious reputation
so that
effectively
i can dismiss my colleagues and continue
to stay in the game because the main
product here is is that we have a
certain amount of prestige now i've made
the decision
that you cannot actually pursue this
within the academic community stephen
wolfram has bounced out having a
a company to support his research
garrett leacy has made shrewd
investments julian barbour translates
things the the problem is that we've had
a catastrophe
in the culture of academics due to the
fact that it had a period of rapid
expansion
and when that came to an end it became
sort of the ponzi scheme meets the
hunger games so what you find out when
you release one of these things is is
that nobody is really taking these
theories seriously davina why are people
not taking this stuff seriously
well
because
i mean
so
it depends on exactly what you're
talking about i think that the different
theories of everything have different
problems um
like i mean for example like the your
random
engineer who writes to me
i don't take this seriously because
those are normally people
who
don't understand the problem they're
trying to solve in the first place
they don't reach the scientific standard
or in many cases
what's actually happening is that they
are reinventing an idea that physicists
have discarded long ago because they
understood that it doesn't work so that
this happens more often than uh than you
may think
now
if i may add a little historical
perspective
i think what's happened in the
foundations of physics is
that we had all those successes coming
from unification
which um michael and brian were already
alluding to earlier um so we unified the
electric anthropomagnetic force to the
electromagnetic and then we had the
electroweak unification and now we have
the standard model and gravity and we've
had this since the 1970s
and um at that moment in time the
reasonable thing to do was to go for an
even bigger unification right because
that had worked before and that's
exactly what physicists um did they
develop string theory for it for a
different purpose but then they figured
out okay it contains something that
looks like gravity maybe that'll do the
trick
and then there were also those ideas of
grand unified uh theories um that made
some predictions that people looked for
in the 1980s for example that protons
should decay but protons were not seen
to decay and those theories were ruled
out and uh string theory well we know
how this went right it never made any
concrete predictions
uh and then was kind of super symmetry
was kind of outsourced and that made
some predictions ran into conflict with
experiments and then it was um amended
and then now it's run into conflict with
experiment again and now people are
fudging it again
and i i think the problem we have in
academia there
is that
people tried something and it didn't
work and they didn't get the message and
now they're just trying the same thing
over and over and over again and it
still doesn't work so i agree that we
need some uh some new ideas uh some new
inspiration just to that people
stop doing the same thing over and over
again and inventing some new particles
which that are then never found it's
just not going anywhere
eric very briefly
this is a primary confusion we have
ideas and we have instantiations let's
just take what sabine has said about
grand unified theories the original su5
grand unified theory predicted proton
decay at a particular scale we didn't
see it when we filled up a mine
with fluid to look for this it doesn't
rule out the petit salon theory it
doesn't rule out different versions of
it and in the case of supersymmetry
supersymmetry is an abstract idea what
we've invalidated is various
instantiations of an abstract idea and
we've pushed it into a realm of
unnaturality now sabine is quite correct
that most of these people
become very attached to whatever they've
said because it fixes to their ego we
all are in danger of this but the idea
that's really important is what happens
if for example the affine space you're
supposed to be trying this on is not
minkowski space but the space of
connection that would be a different
instantiation what if the right group to
be looking at is a different version
derock in his 1963 scientific american
art pointed out that schroedinger
his initial formulation and
instantiation was wrong but the theory
was right
the key problem is is that we have to
give up on bad instantiations and
continue to push the ideas that have yet
to find their correct instantiation
thank you eric brian is it possible to
imagine a future where academics will
agree on a theory of everything and i
think you already started off saying
there is no such thing as a theory of
everything but please give us your
concluding thoughts brian
well bringing us back from theory of
everything to the kind of theory that
we've really been focusing upon in this
conversation some sort of unified
description of the fundamental laws the
fundamental particles putting gravity
into the story putting quantum mechanics
into the story i do think that it's
quite possible and indeed likely that
there will come a point where we do have
the theory that the majority of the
academic community will agree upon now
some would suggest that we're further
along that road than perhaps some of the
other discussants today
would agree on is string theory that
theory i don't know nobody does but i
will say
that this general view that string
theory is stagnant or
somehow its main role is to keep string
theorists employed and to keep other
voices and other ideas out of the
discussion certainly doesn't resonate or
align with my experience over the past
30 years
my experience is that physicists are
generally interested in
heading toward the truth
and are open to ideas that really feel
like they're doing that and so if
someone comes along tomorrow with a
mathematical proof
that string theory that we thought was
internally consistent mathematically if
there's a real flaw
that kills string theory mathematically
the community will not try to continue
to support it if it's a convincing
argument the community will move on
because most of us or promises that
speak for myself think you go around
once
you live once and our goal is to
contribute to this inexorable drive
toward a deeper understanding of the
world and if strength theory is not that
theory i would love to know that today
if there's a proof that shows that the
mathematics doesn't work
and i'd be willing to drop it completely
and move on now that hasn't happened i
suspect it won't happen
but indeed the general
psychological orientation of most of us
is
let us try to press forward to a deeper
understanding of the world that's what
matters
thank you brian and thank you so so much
to my four speakers this evening who
were just simply fantastic there wasn't
enough time really was there to debate
but um we will carry on thank you
everyone